So to describe the ideas that are discussed in this distributed file
system lesson, I have to introduce you to a lot of background
technologies. The first background technology that I'm going to introduce you to
is what is called RAID storage. RAID
stands for redundant array of inexpensive disks.
The idea is a given disk may have a certain IO bandwidth available. Now, if
I can string together a number of disks in parallel, then cumulatively I can
get much more IO bandwidth coming out of all of these disks. That's the
idea of the RAID technology, which is
redundant array of inexpensive disks. Since we have
an array of disks, we are also increasing
the probability of failures. And that is why
in the RAID technology they also use an
error correcting technology associated with RAID. And the basic
idea, is that when you write a file, you're going to do the following: You take
a file, let's say the file has four parts to it. What I'm going to do, is when
I write this file, I'm going to write part one to this disk, part two to this
disk, three to this and four to this.
Because my data is on multiple disks, I'm also
increasing the chance that there may be failures
that can hurt me. And therefore, what we do
is we compute a checksum for this particular
data that I've stored on these disks and store
that in a fifth disk. And this is
what is called Error Correcting Code. So an Error
Correcting Code allows errors to be detected when
I read things from the disk and I see,
oh, something is wrong I can correct it
using this extra information that I'm writing on the
fifth disk here. So that's the big picture
of how striping a file to multiple disks works.
Basically, what we do is we take a file
and decide that if it is going to be striped
over four disks, we stripe it on the four
disks and we also write an error correcting code for
the data that we have striped across these disks.
So that if in fact there is an error that
manifests itself in the future, with anyone of these disks
that error can be corrected using this error correcting data
that we have written to augment the original
data. So failure protection is being achieved through this
error correction code. That's the idea of striping
a file in the RAID system, the drawback in
the RAID technology is first of all the
cost. The fact that we have to have multiple
hardware drives in order to store a single
file. And the second problem is what is called
a small write problem and that is if my file
is really really small, then I'm saying that a part
of this file is going to be written on each one
of these disks, and that's inefficient in terms of how
you store data. And the reason why it is inefficient
of course is the fact if it is a small
file and I've striped it across multiple disks, in order
to read this small file, I have to get data
from all of these disks, and that's inefficient.
And that's the thing that is detrimental about the
hardware RAID in terms of handling a normal file
system that may have a population of small files
and large files, and so on and so forth. But the idea of having an array of
disks to serve the file system is a good
one, because it increases the overall I/O bandwidth that's
available in the server. So, how can we solve the small write problem?